you've leaving behind them a horrifying
evidence and you've seen it you reported
it your folks and by the way i i i don't
say this often but i think we should
give enormous credit to folks with your
agencies that are on the ground in
ukraine in these spots and uh they're
really uh
i've spoken to several of them it's uh
we owe them
but uncovering these evidences of their
atrocities and war crimes against
ukrainian people is so clear to the
whole world now now they've launched and
refocused their campaign to seize new
territory in eastern ukraine
and we're in a critical window now of
time where
that they're going to set the stage for
the next phase of this war
and the united states and our allies and
partners are moving as fast as possible
to continue to provide ukraine the
forces that they need the weapons they
need excuse me the equipment they need
their forces need to defend their nation
last week i signed an 800 million dollar
package of security assistance to
ukraine that included new capabilities
like artillery systems and armored
personnel carriers equipment that is
responsive to ukraine's needs and
tailored to support the intensified
fighting in the donbass region which is
a different war than in other places
because both topographically it's
different it's flat it's it's not in the
mountains and it requires different
kinds of weapons to be
more effective today i'm announcing
another 800 million dollars to further
augment ukraine's ability to fight in
the east in the donbass region this
package includes heavy artillery weapons
with dozens of howitzers and 144 000
rounds of ammunition to go with those
howitzers it also includes more tactical
drones
in the past two months we've moved
weapons and equipment to ukraine at
record speed we've sent thousands of
anti-armor and anti-missile helicopters
drones grenade launchers machine guns
rifles radar systems
more than 50 million rounds of
ammunition at arduino center the united
states alone has provided 10 anti-armor
systems for every one russian tank
that's in ukraine a 10 to 1 ratio
we're sharing and will continue to share
significant timely intelligence with
ukraine to help defend them against
russian aggression and on top of this
these direct contributions from the
united states we're facilitating we're
the outfit facilitating the significant
flow of weapons and systems to ukraine
from other allies and partners around
the world
like the s 300 long-range anti-aircraft
systems that's slovakia recently
transferred to ukraine we are getting
them in there
we won't always be able to advertise
everything we that our partners are
doing to support ukraine and fight for
freedom but to modernize teddy
roosevelt's famous advice sometimes it
will speak softly and carry a large
javelin because we're sending a lot of
those in as well
you know but we're not we're not sitting
on the funding that congress has
provided for ukraine
we're sending it directly to the front
lines of freedom
to the fearless and skilled ukrainian
fighters who are standing in the breach
you got to admit you must be amazed at
the courage of this country the resolve
that they're showing
not just the military military but the
average citizen
men and women young young men young
women as well
it's you know the sustained and
coordinated support of the international
community led and facilitated by the
united states has is a significant
reason why ukraine is able to stop
russia from taking over their country
thus far
every american taxpayer
every member of our armed forces can be
proud of the fact that our country's
generosity and the skill and service of
our military helped arm and repel
russia's aggression in ukraine
to beat back
putin's savagery that tried to seize
ukraine's capital and wipe out ukraine's
government the battle of kyiv was a
historic victory for the ukrainians
it was a victory for freedom
won by the ukrainian people with
unprecedented assistance by the united
states and our allies and our partners
now
now we have to accelerate that
assistance package to help prepare
ukraine for russia's offensive that's
going to be more limited in terms of
geography but not in terms of brutality
not in terms of brutality
combined with our recent drawdowns it
will ensure a steady flow of weapons and
equipment into ukraine over the next few
weeks however
with this latest disbursement
i've almost exhausted the drawdown
authority i have that congress
authorized for ukraine in a bipartisan
spending bill last month in order to
sustain ukraine for the duration of this
fight next week i'm going to have to be
sending to congress a supplemental
budget request to keep weapons and
ammunition flowing without interruption
to the brave ukrainian fighters and
continue to deliver economic assistance
to the ukrainian people
hope
my hope is my expectation is congress
would move and act quickly
i want to thank the congress democrats
and republicans for their support for
the people of ukraine
our unity at home
our unity with our allies and partners
and our unity with the ukrainian people
is sending an unmistakable message to
putin
he will never succeed in dominating and
occupying all of ukraine he will not
that will not happen
in addition to bolstering ugraing's
resistance on the battlefield we're also
demonstrating our support for the people
of ukraine today the united states is
announcing that we intend to provide an
additional 500 million dollars in direct
economic assistance to the ukrainian
government
this brings our total economic support
for ukraine to one billion dollars in
the past two months
this is money the government can help
use to stabilize their economy to
support communities that have been
devastated by the russian onslaught
and pay the brave workers that continue
to provide essential services to the
people of ukraine
you know these past weeks have seen a
terrible human cost of putin's ambition
for conquest and control
approximately two-thirds
two-thirds of all ukrainian children
have been displaced in their home
more than five million ukrainians have
fled their country
it's an absolute outrage
the idea this is happening
approaching the second quarter of the
21st century is just
last month when i was in europe i
announced the united states would
welcome 100 000 ukrainians
so that we share in the responsibility
of supporting ukrainians fleeing putin's
war machine
we've already welcomed tens of thousands
of ukrainians to the united states and
today
i'm announcing a program unite for
ukraine
a new program to enable ukrainians
seeking refuge to come directly from
europe to the united states
this new humanitarian parole program
will complement the existing legal
pathways available to ukrainians
including
immigrant visas and refugees processing
it will provide an expedient channel for
secure legal migration from europe to
the united states for ukrainians who
have a u.s sponsor such as a family or
an ngo
this program will be fast it will be
streamlined and will ensure the united
states honors its commitment to go to
the people of ukraine and need not go
through our southern border
we're also continuing to ratchet up the
pressure on putin and further isolate
russia on the world stage
yesterday the treasury department rolled
out additional measures to crack down on
the entities and individuals attempting
to evade our unprecedented sanctions not
just ours but throughout the west
today i'm announcing that the united
states will ban
russian-affiliated ships from our ports
as they did in europe that means no ship
no ship that sails under the russian
flag or that is owned or operated by a
russian interest will be allowed to dock
in the united states port or access our
shores none
none
this is yet another critical step we're
taking in concert with our partners in
european union united kingdom canada and
further to deny
russia the benefits of international
economic system that they so enjoyed in
the past
we don't know how long this war will
last
but as we approach the two-month mark
here's what we do know
putin has failed to achieve his grand
ambitions on the battlefield
after weeks of shelling keem
keefe still stands
president zielinski and his democratic
elected government still remain in power
and ukrainian armed forces joined by
many brave ukrainian civilians have
fought at russia's conquest of their
country
they've been bolstered from day one by
an unstinting supply of weapons
ammunition armor intelligence from the
nations of the free world led by us the
united states
as russia continues to grind out the
military advances
and their military advances in the
brutalities against ukraine putin is
banking on us losing interest
that's been my view you heard me say
this from the beginning
he was counting on nato european union
our allies in in asia cracking moving
away
he's betting on western unity will crack
he's still betting on that
and once again we're going to prove him
wrong
we will not lessen our evolve
we're going to continue to stand with
the brave and proud people of ukraine
we will never fail in our determination
to defend freedom and oppose tyranny
it's as simple as that
so again i want to thank the american
people
thank the american people for their
support
of the ukrainian people
this is our this is our responsibility
it seems to me and we've been able to
hold the whole world together in this
effort
so thank you very much thank you
i'm going to take this one or two
questions
well first of all it's questionable
whether he does control mario paul one
thing for sure we know about maripo
he should allow humanitarian carters to
let people on that steel mill and other
places are buried under rubble to get
out to get out
that's what any any
any head of state would do in such a
circumstance and so
there is no evidence yet
that mary paul is completely fall
are you considering delaying lifting
title
no what i'm considering is continuing to
hear from my uh my
first of all there's going to be an
appeal
by the justice department
because as a matter of principle we want
to be able to be in a position where if
in fact it is strongly concluded by
the
scientists that we need title 42 that
we'd be able to do that but there has
been no decision on extending title 42.
thank you
how long can the u.s maintain the level
and pace of this military support for
ukraine
i well we have the capacity to do this
for a long time
the question is
are we going to continue to
maintain
the support of the international
community
and keep the pressure
on putin to prevent him from overrunning
the country number one and number two
make sure we continue to maintain the
economic sanctions which over time and
we're beginning to see they're
devastating their economy and their
ability to move forward so the most
important thing right now
is maintain the unity so far so good
thank you very much
thank you
you